economía en directo América de Francia
24 y Juan Pablo lucumillas está
alistando en nuestra mesa de trabajo
para hablar de un dato fresquito Juan
Pablo que acaba de salir el de inflación
de Estados Unidos subió bajo se quedó
igual que está pasando así es Raúl pues
hace pocos minutos se conoció lo que
usted decía el dato de inflación anual
de diciembre en Estados Unidos
ubicándose en 6,5% algo de lo que ya se
hablaba en los mercados mundiales previo
a conocerse el dato y que hizo que las
bolsas se operara con la expectativa de
un enfriamiento de la economía y una
posible reducción en las tasas de
interés de la reserva Federal que se
reunirá en los próximos meses hace una
hora también Hablamos precisamente aquí
en esta sección que el mercado esperaba
un 6,5 y como puede ver acertaron así
las cosas el nuevo dato de inflación
quedó por debajo del 7,1% de noviembre y
muy por debajo del máximo de 40 años del
9,1% en junio Bueno vamos a ver si esto
entonces sigue bajando Ojalá sea Estados
Unidos sino para todos los países sobre
todo de nuestra región sí de manera
general Juan Pablo vamos ahora a hablar
de la caída de los rendimientos de los
bonos de esta vez de la zona Euro Porque
casi cada año en enero se presentan esta
actividad particular que este año no ha
sido la excepción de qué se trata Juan
Pablo hablamos de la gran oferta de
bonos que se presenta en la zona Euro
cada enero que realmente también se
encuentra con una buena demanda pero la
cantidad de nuevas ofertas de deuda que
se han presentado en estos primeros 12
días del año han causado la caída en el
rendimiento de dichos bonos siguiendo el
principio básico económico que reza que
si la mayor que si la oferta es mayor
que la demanda los precios tienden a
bajar este jueves España Italia Francia
Países Bajos y Noruega emitieron bonos
programados para vender nueva deuda a
diferentes fechas de vencimiento sólo
esta semana ya se han producido
alrededor de 30.000 millones de euros en
nuevas emisiones de los gobiernos de la
zona Euro Y todavía queda por conocerse
la oferta del Banco Central europeo que
planea empezar a deshacerse de algunos
de esos bonos que han acumulado durante
la última década y seguimos en Europa y
vamos a hablar de la escasez de la mano
de obra en Alemania Así es Raúl según
los datos de la cámara de comercio de
industria de Alemania las dificultades
para contratar a personas ha calificado
esta vez en su nivel más alto cuando en
una encuesta rojo que por lo menos el
53% de las 22.000 empresas que se
encuestaron habían reportado no poder
cubrir todas sus vacantes la encuesta
encontró que el 67% de los fabricantes
de equipos eléctricos no pudieron cubrir
las vacantes el 67% de las empresas de
ingeniería mecánica tampoco lo lograron
y el 65% de las compañías de fabricación
de automóviles fueron otras de las que
reportaron escasez en la mano de obra
Juan Pablo Vamos hasta Rusia porque el
kremlin dijo hoy jueves que no se ha
visto afectado con lo que le puso la
Unión Europea los precios al tope de su
petróleo esto el año pasado Así es Y fue
específicamente el portavoz del kreming
Dimitri prescott quien aseguró que no
había visto casos puntuales en los que
el tope de 60 dólares por barril
transportado por mar que impuso
occidente como lo decía usted en
diciembre afectará realmente a Rusia
Esto fue lo que él dijo
en lo que respecta a las pérdidas nadie
ha visto Especialmente los límites
máximos todavía como saben tenemos un
decreto presidencial para enviar
petróleo los países que tienen precios
máximos Y esta es la razón por la que
consideramos con escepticismo Tales
estimaciones de pérdidas
multimillonarias rusas debido al tope de
precios
algunos analistas han dicho
anteriormente que los topes tendrán poco
impacto inmediato en los ingresos
petroleros que Moscú está obteniendo
actualmente por ahora los precios de la
mayoría del crudo ruso siguen
cotizándose de forma general por debajo
de ese nivel máximo de los 60 dólares
por barril es decir no los afecta bueno
Juan Pablo en noticias de Asia salieron
ya los reportes de rendimiento de una de
las empresas más más importantes en
fabricación de chips esto en Taiwán y
estamos hablando de ti es MC el mayor
fabricante por contrato de chips de
procesadores para teléfonos inteligentes
y otros productos quien anunció este
jueves que sus ganancias aumentaron un
78% en el último trimestre de 2022
comparadas con el mismo periodo de 2021
los ingresos totales en ese periodo de
comparación también crecieron un 42,8%
hasta los
20.600 millones de dólares 10 en sí
fabrica chips de procesadores para
marcas como Apple Inc y qualcom Inc y
muchos de sus productos son ensamblados
por fábricas en China lo que ha expuesto
a esta empresa atenciones con Estados
Unidos y su papel en el mundo de la
tecnología y la seguridad que nos trae
como cifra del día Juan Pablo 182 mil
millones de dólares es lo que ha perdido
el multimillonario Tecnológico elon musk
desde noviembre de 2021 según el informe
de guinness World Records se estima que
gran parte de esta pérdida se debe a la
caída en el precio de las acciones de
tesla pero el declive se aceleró desde
que hemos comprado Twitter compró
Twitter toda esta polémica que vimos a
lo largo del año pasado Juan Pablo como
siempre Gracias por toda la información
económica nos vemos después nos vemos
después nos vemos no mañana y pasamos a
saludar a Luis Miguel Cabrera en